365 days of War and the Grim toll of
human suffering in Ukraine Russia and
Beyond keeps Rising tens of thousands of
soldiers from both sides have died on
the front lines and as towns cities and
Villages across Ukraine come under
Russian fire people endured the pain and
despair of losing their loved ones more
than seven thousand civilians have now
been killed in Ukraine including in
areas occupied by Russian forces
millions of mostly women and children
have been uprooted from their families
in comfort of their homes to shelter
from the war and yet there's no Prospect
of peace I'm Darian abogado welcome to
an Al Jazeera NewsHour special Ukraine
war one year on
and I'm Adrian Finnegan live in Kiev the
capital of Ukraine a nation that's
mourning the fallen and vowing to fight
on to Victory
one year ago today missiles fighter jets
and ground troops took part in Russia's
full-scale invasion of Ukraine but as
the war enters its second year Ukraine
bolstered by Western support still
stands and President Vladimir zielinski
has pledged to win the war against
Russia this year
let's head to downtown Kiev where my
colleague Zane Bas Ravi is standing by
saying how has today been marked
well this has been a somber occasion no
large scale events but people have been
going to churches lighting candles for
loved ones lost in the fight praying for
the ones that are headed to the front
line praying for each other one
Ukrainian told me that this is not just
a war that's been going on for a year or
even since 2014 they feel at a very
existential level that this country has
been pushing back against Russian
influence against Russian aggression in
one way or another for centuries and it
was a time to look back but Ukraine's
people and Ukraine's leadership is now
very squarely as the day is winding down
looking forward President zielinski
Vladimir zielinski met the Polish prime
minister today who was in town who came
to visit Ukraine to mark this
anniversary Poland has for the longest
time even since before this conflict
began been a very close Ally of
Ukraine's a very hawkish European
country when it comes to Russia has been
sounding the alarm for a while the
Polish leader brought with him four
leopard tanks delivered them to Mark the
occasion of the anniversary of this war
and said 14 more as promised will be on
the way soon weapons that Ukraine says
it sorely needs to continue to fight
Russia and to push them back and to have
a victory in this conflict you know
we've been speaking to communities all
over Kiev region and really they just
want to get back to normal they just
want peace they just want to move on and
and simply exist as a country as a
Sovereign Nation one of the things that
communities keep telling us is that this
war has been an enormous disruption to
daily life that feels like an
understatement one of the things they
keep saying to us is they can't even
send their children to school they're
too scared of Russian missiles and
drones some schools have reopened with
bomb shelters in the schools for the
children to try to make parents feel
safe enough to send their kids back to
school so their education is not
disrupted we visited one school in or
pin to try to understand the reality of
being a student in Wartime Ukraine
far from the fighting children in
Ukraine are still connected to it by
family members on the front line and the
more immediate threat of bombs from the
sky
my children get scared when there is an
air right siren They Know What to Do
they hide but the first time my son was
crying he told me he was very scared he
thought that everyone would die and his
mum was not close by our children do not
deserve that they should not be asking
if Rockets were launched or not
parents we met said Schools central to
their community and to stability in
their children's lives were not spared
in Russia's bombardments
UNICEF estimates half of all schools
across Ukraine are too damaged to reopen
and two-thirds of its children are
unable to access any kind of Education
some of the schools in areas that were
held by the Russians are so heavily
damaged from shelling that it will take
millions of dollars and years before
they're ready to open for students again
one school principal said in the
aftermath of Russia's occupation of his
hometown reopening classrooms meant
making sure parents felt safe enough to
send their children back
with the help of international donors
this school in European converted a
storage basement into an air raid
shelter
the plan is to build spaces like this in
as many schools as possible
the biggest concern for us is the
children there are children and we are
responsible for them that's why at the
beginning of the school year we
organized first aid classes and
psychological training to cope with fear
when we have Sirens all the children
automatically come to the shelter they
know how to respond and what to do
foreign
but it is not ideal the student body at
this school numbered in the thousands
before the war
now only 200 children attend at a time
and only for a few hours a day because
that is the maximum number of children
that will fit in the shelter
school schedules made to accommodate the
threat of Russian attacks
it is purpose built to be child friendly
but not fortified or deep enough to
withstand a direct hit
every time an air raid alarm stops and
the all clear sounds the hope is they
will never have to use it again
Zane basavi Al Jazeera or pen
joining me now is Valen de Rozier the
head of operations for the International
Federation of the Red Cross here in
Ukraine uh good to have you with us
villain what is the Red Cross doing in
Ukraine right now so the Red Cross is
providing humanitarian assistance to
population across the country in all
regions of the country
primarily in health so we have emergency
Health teams that are providing
immediate life-saving support to to
population especially in the East we are
also providing cash assistance to people
to help them repair the their destroyed
houses or host people who host families
who have lost their houses we are also
providing very basic items like hygiene
kits and blankets and everything from
generators to heaters for the winter so
really essential items for people to to
go through a
the difficulties that that they are
facing at the moment including food and
and things like that Red Cross teams are
operating right out there on on the
front lines at the moment what are they
telling you about conditions where the
the fighting is fiercest so the
conditions are very very difficult they
are difficult for the people on the
front lines but they're also difficult
for many people also that had to to flee
those those areas
the main uh the main needs at the moment
of course is the emergency help needs
because there's a lot of wounded people
there's a lot of people who are
traumatized we're providing psychosocial
support to these people we're also
evacuating so so far in the last year we
evacuated more than 350 000 people from
those areas to to take them out either
to hospitals or to Safe places
um and and so yeah it's it's ongoing on
a daily basis away from the front lines
that are concerns of Mental Health
crisis in Ukraine what role can the Red
Cross play in mitigating that so you
know the Red Cross has a network of
volunteers across the country we are in
every single villages
in Ukraine so there is a very wide
network of volunteers that are trained
to provide psychological first aid for
instance but we also have first aid
psychological support centers where
people can come they can get support
from a psychologists their kids can also
have some some activities right now we
are providing support to more than 15
million people in Ukraine and and this
is we see the numbers are increasing
over time
even if the conflict ends this year as
president zielinski says that it will
Ukraine is going to need for support for
years to come isn't it yeah so yeah we
we are seeing that this war is is gonna
go on for for a long time we are also
preparing uh to
welcome back some some refugees you know
a lot of 8.5 million people have fled
the country but 75 percent of those
people they want to come back and and
ukrainians have shown incredible
resilience they want to come back they
don't necessarily want to stay even if
there is a war in their country so we
are also preparing that's the next phase
of our operation here is to see how we
can support the reintegration of those
people so they can go back to their
homes or if that's not possible then we
can also support them in different parts
of the country good to talk to you Billy
many thanks indeed for being with us
here on Al Jazeera
that was the villain de Rozier head of
the operations or head of operations for
the international uh Red Cross
Adrian thank you so much well in Russia
no major public events have been held to
Mark the anniversary of what President
Vladimir Putin calls a special military
operation thousands of people who oppose
the conflict or wanted to avoid
conscription have left and here is what
some residents of Moscow said how they
feel about the war
my expectations I want this to be over
as soon as possible of course we're
waiting for Russia to win in the special
military operation the whole world's
against us NATO countries are fighting
us through Ukraine supplying them with
equipment and then there are the Nazis
we're looking forward to winning this
year hopefully the sooner the better for
this to end
what is of course bad but this year has
shown that no other decision could have
been taken and that we are defending our
independence Freedom a chance for the
future the future of our children
therefore we want Victory
I really want peace I really wanted all
to end as soon as possible too many
victims morally speaking and materially
we pensioners feel it all
Osama bin Javed reports now from Moscow
on how the nation is rallying behind
President Putin
but in the last year A lot has changed a
year ago there were sanctions almost
every day being piled on Russia tens of
thousands of people had left Russia that
included the bright the brightest and
the best that it had but in a year there
seems to be a change of opinion people
have now come round to the narrative
that has been built by the Russian
government that this is an existential
War this is a war that Russia had to go
to because it had no other choice
because it is fighting a coalition of
countries not just Ukraine and it caused
Ukraine a proxy Army it has been able to
tell its people that in the past year
that an alliance of countries came
together and wanted to destroy Russia
they wanted to decapitate the Russian
leadership it's been telling its people
that they have failed in Breaking
Russia's economy in defeating Russia's
military or isolating Russia
internationally a proof of which is
today when China has presented its peace
plan which which remains a steadfast
partner for Russia so despite all of
these sanctions despite so much being
pulled out of Russia Russia has been
able to withstand it it has been able to
circumvent a lot of these sanctions and
life goes on in the Russian Capital as
well although without those many
recognizable International Brands those
uh those stations those coffee shops
those cafes are still open despite them
changing their names to Russian ones and
ownership changing to Russia
tree is a standard 1.5 liter family car
but it comes off the production line of
what used to be a Renault production
plant when the French car manufacturer
left Russia last year it brought off 2.3
billion dollars worth of assets and sold
its Russian subsidiary for a symbolic 1
euro
it has a buyback option in a few years
if sanctions are lifted but for now the
45 000 workers who produced nearly a
third of Russia's car market remain
employed yet it seems one company
sanctions crisis was another's
opportunity
in 2023 we plan to produce 50 000
Vehicles 10 000 will be electric we've
already started developing our own
electric platform by the end of 2025 we
plan to produce a fully electric car of
our own design we plan to localize all
components in Moscow
fast food chains in cafes which closed
operations have also been acquired by
Russian business people so McDonald's is
now the kuzno itachika and Starbucks is
star's coffee in Russia
more than 11 000 sanctions have been
imposed during this year they assumed
that events would unfold in a
catastrophic way Russia's exports would
go to zero Russia would fall into a
complete blockade the financial system
will collapse however they were wrong
these countries have either imposed
restrictions backed sanctions or opposed
Russia's invasion of Ukraine but the
ones in green are either seen as
Russia's allies or have a neutral stance
these include South America's Brazil and
Venezuela plus resource-rich Nations
including Iraq Mali and Sudan and Asia's
powerhouses including India and China
this is the klashnikov group showcasing
its weapons in the United Arab Emirates
it's one of many countries that refused
to be involved in sanctions against
Russia the Russian manufacturer produces
about 95 percent of all small arms in
the country and exports weapons to more
than 27 others
Russian drug makers have turned to
India's Pharma industry for supplies
after being blocked by the West India
has also become a major oil export
market for Russia
but China dwarfs them all with an
estimated 200 billion dollars in trade
forecasts with Russia by next year
despite its allies help sanctions
against Russia have led to a drop in
exports a widening fiscal deficit and
businesses struggling to find cash after
banking restrictions
one year on Moscow has proved an old
military saying Russia is never as
strong as you fear but Russia is also
never as weak as you hope
Moscow
oh President Vladimir Putin has framed
the war as a fight for Russia's
existence and he's blamed the West for
stoking the conflict NATO the world's
largest military Alliance is standing by
Ukraine with weapons and Aid and the U.S
has approved an additional two billion
dollars in military aid on the
anniversary of the start of the war
along with Maura sweeping sanctions
Paddy Calhoun reports from Washington
a day after this began the U.S president
asked Congress for 3.5 billion dollars
in military aid for Ukraine a year later
the amount has increased almost 10 fold
in the beginning the U.S provided
Stinger anti-aircraft systems and
javelin's anti-armor systems portable
easy to use weapons designed to Target
Planes and tanks but as the months have
passed and the battle lines have shifted
analysts say a pattern has emerged the
bite Administration has taken an
iterative approach building on past
deliveries to Ukraine testing the waters
seeing the reaction both from the
International Community and Russia and
then escalating the sophistication and
volume of assistance from there over the
course of the year the US has continued
to supply stingers and javelins adding
in switchblades known as suicide drones
and howitzers basically mobile cannons
and the rounds that go with it they've
provided air defense systems naysams
which is for shorter to medium range
intercepts and also the Patriot defense
system which is meant for longer range
intercepts they've provided highmars
that is a GPS guided rocket system that
has allowed the ukrainians to Target
Russians further from the front lines
and now Abrams tanks although the
Pentagon says they're having those built
along with training that likely means
they won't be on the battlefield anytime
soon it's a long list that the U.S
continues to add to each time U.S
officials debating and assessing if it
will cross Russia's red line which some
Russian experts say could happen if
Russia's President Vladimir Putin thinks
he's losing one of the things that
Russia could do is to take out you know
one or more of the satellites that that
allow Ukraine to use this
precision-guided munition
Arsenal effectively
um those satellites are in fact
vulnerable and there are a lot of things
that the Russians could do to interfere
with them and and that that would
certainly be a dangerous escalatory step
a year in the ukrainians are asking for
longer range weapons and fighter jets so
far President Joe Biden has been clear
on his answer
to Ukraine an answer he's given before
the ukrainians hoping once again they
can help change his mind
Al Jazeera Washington
let's now cross over to Moscow we're
going to speak to Pavel falgenhauer
who's an independent defense analyst
joining us uh from there Mr falkenhauer
welcome to Al Jazeera so as Western
countries pledge more and more uh
military at Ukraine from a military
standpoint what's your analysis of where
the war will head to next as it enters
its second year
well this is a right now a bloody
stalemate there
the front line has not changed much in
the last several months after the
Russian forces withdrew from the right
Bank of the nepro river and the pendant
Harrison which was a very important move
because that meant that the Russian
forces the Russian command and basically
forsaken any possibility of any major
strategic offenses for the time being
they cannot move to the minister or
never any other place because they're
now only on the Left Bank of the nipro
so this is since then it's a stalemate
situation pitched battles around
and other places in donbass with very
slow progress right speaking of the
donors let me ask you I mean will Russia
chance to hold on to the areas that is
captured and expanded control obviously
the donbass region is important for
Russia and Putin has prioritized as he
says liberating the whole of donbass
well yes politically it's very important
but we're terribly right now these
battles do not are not significant in
themselves I mean the places they're
fighting for like Bahamut does not have
any real strategic value in itself but
that's important psychologically and it
seems that the Russian idea the strategy
is to draw to exhaust the Ukrainian
forces exhaust the Ukrainian Nation
break their morale their their desire
and capability to fight on apparently
the Kremlin believes that the Russian
people have more will and more manpower
actually yeah
despite Moscow having had more soldiers
more weapons and more aircraft why do
you think that it hasn't secured a
decisive win over Kiev yet
uh well there was apparently a very
serious mistake in calculation of what
the Ukraine how Ukraine will resist how
the Ukrainian military can fight
and that happened already a year ago
basically in the first two weeks of the
conflict uh the Russian Blitz
faltered and since then it's been a war
of attrition so now the Russian
leadership believes they can win a war
of attrition that the West is going to
get started of this war and supporting
Ukraine Ukrainian military will be
exhausted the Ukrainian people lose
their desire to fight and in the end the
Russia will be successful and that seems
to be the operating alongside the
Russian military has been the mercenary
private Wagner group to what extent did
their involvement Aid Russian advances
well they have been used as Frontline
cracks storm troops that's how they were
used actually in Syria but in much much
less numbers in Syria because because
the Russians were bombing and the Syrian
government forces should have gone
forward but didn't and so they deployed
the Wagner's not the same as happening
in the donbass Russian regulars
apparently are not ready to go and die
in such numbers as the above nurses
which are sending in actually
felons who volunteered to go out of
prison for a pardon and they are ready
to fight this bloody battle but the
existence of such a private Army within
the Russian ranks well that demonstrates
problems within the Russian regular
military
our rights on that nose we'll have to
leave it there we thank you so much for
joining us from Moscow
thank you
now Russia's Invasion has turned the
focus on its billionaires those with
close links to President Putin on the
Kremlin have been hit with sweeping
International sanctions their property
and assets Frozen and seized the British
Capital London was once regarded as a
favorite playground of the Russian Elite
Paul Brennan looks at what they're doing
now
Russia's post-soviet millionaires the
white stucco Mansions of London's
Belgravia were an irresistible magnet a
wash with Russian money districts like
Mayfair Belgravia and Knightsbridge
earned the nickname London grad
U the exclusive Prime real estate agents
of London's Mayfair rode that boom
brokering billions in property deals but
in the past year International sanctions
have brought an end to all that
all doors have come down in terms of
Russians very difficult to work with
Russians because near the banks nor
lawyers are Keen to work with them some
agents won't work with them but it
doesn't really matter because there's
been very few of any Russian inquiries
over the last
eight or ten months
the invasion of Ukraine sparked a
Scramble for the exits realizing that
sanctions were imminent and inevitable
the oligarchs raced to offload their
assets get rid of their football clubs
and sail their motor Yachts out of the
reach of the sanctioning authorities
London grad had become a hostile
environment for Russian money the
shutters came down
in Europe and the United States law
enforcement has been vigorously seizing
billions in russian-linked assets while
new disclosure laws are revealing the
true ownership of thousands of anonymous
offshore holding companies
the anti-corruption group The occrp has
compiled a Russian asset tracker
meticulously listing the Yachts the
mansions and the private jets of many of
the best known Russian Elites the group
says sanctions have meant these
billionaires are now struggling to find
lawyers and financiers willing to work
for them but these are resourceful
people they really do have this oligarch
survival kit that includes you know
multiple citizenships uh passports dummy
companies lots of proxies lots of
digital assets sometimes a lot of Art
and so on and even if we look at at
Europe for instance the UK or
Switzerland or or other countries where
that that were preferred for only a
biology for a long time we see that the
action against these oligarchs is is
barely touching the surface places like
Dubai and turkey remain neutral and are
not imposing sanctions this 250 million
dollar super yacht linked to the
sanctioned oligarch Andre Scotch was
just one of those spotted in Dubai
Harbor
eclipse and Solaris two of Roman
abramovich's Yachts are off Tokyo
a year on from the Russian invasion of
Ukraine at least two billion dollars of
assets have been frozen in the UK alone
but although London is now off limits
the sheer scale of the oligarchs wealth
means that mayor Mountain no more than
an inconvenience
Paul Brennan Al Jazeera Belgravia
well Palestinians have criticized what
they say are double standards in Western
Powers attitudes to Invasion and
occupation many say the International
Community has rushed to sanction Russia
for its war in Ukraine but they argue
they've lived under military occupation
for decades without Israel being held to
account
Ibrahim reports from the occupied West
Bank
foreign
has lived under Israel's military
occupation for the last 30 years a
Ukrainian who married a Palestinian she
now lives in Ramallah in the occupied
West Bank in February last year her
original hometown of mariupal also
became occupied by Russian forces
zvetlana says she never thought in her
life that Palestine would be a refuge
for her family
but after her brother was killed in the
war in Ukraine last year it is with her
80 year old mother fled to
hahaha
into her converter it's your right to
live in peace and for your children to
see Freedom no one should take you right
away this is what the Russians are doing
to ukrainians taking our rights so there
are lots of similarities between
Palestinians and ukrainians
despite being under the military rule of
a foreign power Palestinians say the
world is ignoring their situation
Palestinians say that their struggled
for Independence and freedom is a just
cause victims of a decades-long
occupation they say they can't count on
the International Community which rushed
to sanction Russia while allowing Israel
to get away with its violations I feel
very angered at the double standards of
the European and the Western Nations
where they've been taking the wrong the
wrong side of History against
Palestinians all these years
the world is showing sympathy with
Ukraine but diminishes us the world only
respects the powerful
the big Powers who ruled the world have
double standards it seems that those who
control international law decide who
abides by it
dozens of U.N resolutions support the
Palestinian people's right to
Independence and self-determination and
designate settlements illegal but none
have led to action Palestinian officials
say this shows double standards and it's
not new the problem is that countries
are not willing to uphold International
standards when it comes to Israel and
international human rights law and to
apply the same exact measures that they
apply elsewhere in the world
and this is why we continue to witness
Israel's
non-abidance by international law
like most Palestinians vitlanas is the
war in Ukraine is devastating but hopes
it will end soon
but she and many Palestinians feed
Israel's occupation will go on much
longer
the occupied West Bank
well I'm joined Now by Marwan bishara
he's Al Jazeera senior political analyst
here in Doha uh welcome back Marwan so
how do we explain this double standards
and also when you say that this war has
exposed the limits in outright failure
of the International System where does
that failure lie well it's exactly in
the hypocrisy of superpowers because the
superpowers like the United States and
Russia basically control the world
system they have veto power at the
United Nations security Council and
crippled the United Nations and
undermine the application of
international law whether it is in the
Middle East or in Ukraine whether it's
in Palestine or elsewhere and in a sense
Russia chose a war of choice
in Ukraine it's a horrific disastrous
War
and on the other hand there is this
breathtaking Western hypocrisy because
the West the United States claims that
this is a war
of democracy against dictatorship well
at the same time the United States and
its European allies armed support
numerous dictatorships around the world
and then they turn and say well it's
actually about the respects of for
sovereignty but it's the United States
that violated Iraqi sovereignty and
other countries sovereignties and then
they turn to say Russia has no right to
Annex Ukrainian territories but it's the
United States that recognize Israel's
annexation
of Syrian and Palestinian territories so
the hypocrisy is breathtaking in as much
as the Russian war itself right is
horrific and marijuana one of the uh the
main reasons of this war according to
Moscow of course is NATO's expansionist
Ambitions into Europe uh NATO of course
led by the United States but so far what
we've seen is that NATO has remained
just as defiant as Russia has so what
does this mean as to what happens next
there's no doubt that Russia used the
issue of NATO wanting to expand uh to
the Russian borders meaning to Ukraine
as a pretext for war but the war is war
and it's a war of choice not a war of
Defense it's a war of choice and yet
since 2000 in fact since 2008 I was
there in Bucharest when it was discussed
that NATO would expand to
Georgia and Ukraine the French and the
Germans said no we shouldn't this will
destabilize European security it's it's
a no-go and it was postponed from after
Bucharest but then after 2014 and later
in 2018 it was Revisited again and again
that it should be expanded the Russian
gave the West the near to an ultimate
and they said if you do and if you don't
clear out of our borders something
horror was going to happen and it did
happen so when it comes to this sort of
question of European security the media
especially the Western media tends to be
I don't want to say foolish but
certainly a historical because when it
comes to Russia Ukraine and European
security we're not talking about few
years history we're talking about
centuries of History so it's not just
about
dictatorships and democracy or just
about sovereignty or just about
annexation or just about security it's
also about Europe and its horrific
history of conflict that does include
the Polish and the ukrainians and the
Russians and the French and others of
course Marwan there are other countries
in Africa for example and also in Asia
that don't support Western countries in
their condemnation of Russia and they
don't agree with the U.N on on uh on
sort of pressuring Russia so going
forward do you think that these
divisions are going to deepen well it's
kind of hybrid right so at the United
Nations they vote for the withdrawal
Russia will draw from Ukraine but in
real life they still trade with Russia
get arms from Russia support Russia in
various ways just like when the United
States and Israel are only few or five
that support certain or against certain
resolution and the rest of the world is
against but then they trade with the
United States and have security
agreements with Israel it's a very
hybrid hypocritical word in some ways
but I'll tell you what's what is really
interesting is what happened today with
China right which I wanted to I wanted
to actually ask you about the Chinese
peace proposal and what you think of
that it's really amazing because when I
heard the press conference right with
NATO Secretary General with the Estonia
primers and so on so forth they were
saying no we should not because China
has close relationship with Russia and
China could not be trusted because it
did not take a fundamental position it
has Limitless relation with Russia it's
those same countries the United States
and European powers that insist that
only the United United States can
mediate peace in the Middle East when it
has Limitless unconditional support for
Israel
hypocrisy is just breathtaking once and
again I think China should be taken
seriously it's the only superpower with
leverage with Moscow and hence it could
pressure Russia into a ceasefire and
perhaps into going to before February
22nd uh
2020-22 and when we could see the
beginning of an end to this horrific
disastrous War the fact that Western
powers are rejecting it out of hand that
does not serve the the cause of Peace
what it does now it will simply prolong
the war for God knows when okay Marwan
thank you so much for that analysis well
it's now back to you Adrian and Keith
they're in as the wall grinds on
millions of Ukrainian families remain
separated Poland has welcomed the most
with around one and a half million
people settling there Al jazeera's Jonah
Hull met some refugees there who hoped
to return to their Homeland one day
in a Polish Auditorium Ukrainian
refugees watch a film comparing the
World War II destruction of Warsaw with
last year's Russian bombardment of
mariopol
Warsaw was rebuilt and Rose shiny and
new From the Ashes
so too the thinking goes will Ukraine's
devastated cities like Mario Paul
on a guided tour of Warsaw later where
traces of the war still remain some feel
only faint hope
the variable we had will never be the
different we can how but the life we had
there will never return that life was
stolen from us
hope is a common ingredient in the lives
of Ukrainian refugees scattered the
world over a large proportion benefiting
from the generosity of neighboring
Poland but the warmth and safety of
sponsored accommodation is no barrier to
pain
March 20th was a more or less quiet day
so we left the basement and I remember
it was my daughter's birthday
nor to the realization that what began
as a temporary relocation could last
much longer
and while there are those returning to
safer parts of Ukraine especially as
winter lifts many continue to flee the
fighting in the south and east train
loads of newcomers arrive on Poland's
eastern border almost every day
we sold everything just to have money to
come across you sold all your belongings
yeah
even books
art
and here only my mom
since the War Began more than 8 million
people of disembarked trains like this
one from Ukraine many of them going on
to settle in countries all over the
world while Poland alone has taken in
around one and a half million and this
country's generosity now being sorely
tested as the war goes on
in recent years Poland has become
infamous for its unwelcoming attitude to
migrants from Africa and the Middle East
trying to cross the border from Belarus
not so those from Ukraine but while the
country spends billions of dollars
supporting them and as the cost of
living soars the hope that they'll one
day be able to leave Poland is not felt
by the ukrainians alone
and Jonah joins us now live at a un
Community Center for refugees near the
Polish Ukrainian border children
yeah you know people are still arriving
here every single day crossing the
border from Ukraine the estimate is
around 2 000 people per day remember
people are going the other way to around
1 000 per day of returning to safer
parts of Ukraine and just an hour or so
ago the train arrived the same one you
saw in my report there from zapparija
another train load coming in some of
them ending up in this shelter it's in
fact run by Ukrainian house the cultural
institution based here in Poland and
joining me from Ukrainian house is
Tatiana thank you so much for joining us
Tanya it's not the huge numbers of the
beginning of the war obviously but still
they come yes people are coming as you
said uh when you when you go to the
train station you see as much as 2 000
people coming every day by Only By by
Train uh and that's why we have on the
train station and we have our employees
our volunteers working 24 hours a day
seven days a week because they are
needed there and that's why here in this
shelter we have people all the time we
have refugees we receive refugees here
we have 50 sleeping places people can
stay one two three nights as long as it
takes so yeah we we have let's keep
doing it you've been doing it since the
beginning you're part of this Army of
volunteers ngos other institutions
seeing this unending sort of flow of
misery and despair it can't be easy for
you how do you cope
it's not easy it's it's not easy for
all of us actually but you know I have
this feeling you're much in need yes yes
I have this feeling that this day
started a year ago on 24th of February
2022 and it still has not ended so
that's why we do not have really time to
think about what we see what we how we
feel but actually yes you are right we
we saw so much misery uh so much
unhappiness and still it goes on one
fascinating aspect I just want to touch
on is that this place chenish on the
border was the scene after the second
world war of the most appalling
bloodletting between Ukrainian
nationalists and polls thousands upon
thousands died has this war had the
effect of bringing ukrainians and poles
together again absolutely yes the
history of our Nations is very difficult
especially here in Implement
however when this whole thing started we
did not look who is who we just worked
together and I have this feeling that
from now on we are writing new history I
mean in in some time in a 10 50 100
years we will talk about completely
different history and we will not
remember what happened a hundred years
ago or 80 years ago we will talk about
what's happening between our two Nations
now and this is very very important
fascinating Tanya thank you so much for
joining us so one unintended consequence
of Russia's invasion of Ukraine a new
chapter of History being written between
ukrainians and polls Adrian back to you
thank you
many thanks indeed Jonah hold there live
near the Polish Ukrainian border
let's bring in the unhcr now well we
have Kevin Allen who's the country
representative for Poland at the United
Nations High Commissioner for refugees
he is in Warsaw Kevin good to have you
with us what are the unhcr's priorities
right now in Poland
well uh first and foremost Adrian I I
want to thank you for welcoming me
welcoming me and to acknowledge the
incredible solidarity of Poland you were
just uh speaking with some of the
volunteers and the humanitarian workers
On the Border regions and I think one of
the first priorities uh for unhcr in our
partners is to continue standing firm
with the Ukrainian refugees in this
uncertain situation and at the same time
to stand firm with Poland given its uh
really remarkable hospitality and
solidarity in this context but I also
think it's incumbent that we that we
note the importance of ending the
destruction uh in the senseless killing
in Ukraine which continues to drive as
you've noted uh displacement there's
currently five million people displaced
first from their homes within Ukraine
and eight million people have crossed
the border into Europe about half of
those have gone through Poland and at
this juncture uh we we note that a lot
of refugees the 1.5 million who have
registered here in Poland are doing okay
in the sense that they have access to
health care access to education uh
they're able to work but at the same
time 90 of them are women and children
so you have inherent vulnerabilities
that exist you also have a large number
of people who've experienced severe
psychosocial trauma during flight you
have a an important number of elderly
refugees also disabled persons so
notwithstanding the exemplary solidarity
really of the people of Poland there are
still needs and we need to continue to
stand firmly with the refugees but also
with Poland as a host country at the
same time we know that this is not over
uh the the longer term
looms and the future is not clear
uh in recent surveys that we have done
around 80 percent of refugees say they
would like to go home they'd like to go
back to Ukraine but the single biggest
deterrent the reason that most of them
are not Kevin are not willing to get
back in Sudoku numbers is the ongoing
conflict which brings us back to the uh
initial Kevin that we really need to
stop the uh the senseless killing and
destruction in Ukraine
Kevin I Kevin I don't know whether you
can hear me Kevin we're running out of
time here I just want to get this
question in most of the ukrainians in
Poland right now are women and children
in terms of Education what needs to be
provided if you can give me a reasonably
succinct answer thank you
fortunately the government of Poland has
opened schools to Ukrainian children
they're able to go and study alongside
polish children it's important that we
continue to work with the community to
ensure that the children enroll that
they take advantage of that opportunity
some children are an online curriculum
uh with with Ukrainian language uh
studying in Ukraine from our vantage
point it's also important that they go
to school that they're physically in
school but the government of Poland has
provided that opportunity to all
Ukrainian refugees
Kevin really appreciate you coming on
many thanks indeed Kevin Allen there
with the UN Refugee agency in Poland now
many ukrainians have returned to their
homes since those initial weeks of the
war but for those who fled from regions
that are still under Russian control
that kind of homecoming is harder to
imagine as villain marks reports now
from the UK
Alessia sidorenko had been saving money
for months to take her two sons on an
overseas vacation she never imagined it
would fund their escape from a war zone
I woke up at four o'clock in the morning
24 4th of February
when it I heard terrible explosion for
days she slept beneath the bombardments
in a nearby hospital basement with
eight-year-old Nikita and 14 year old
artem two months on the teenager told
her he'd had enough he started to Christ
one day and said to me how man how much
money we need to leave the Ukraine she
spent a small fortune traveling to
Crimea further inside Russian occupied
territory then on to Georgia turkey and
eventually the English town of Worthing
part of a wave of ukrainians Welcome to
the UK under a government resettlement
program
in the months that followed the February
Invasion tens of thousands of British
families of all different backgrounds
whether based in remote villages in the
far north of Scotland or Coastal
communities like this one on the
southern edge of England volunteered to
host ukrainians in their homes
among them was retiree Janet Atkinson
who says she felt she had to help out
however she could and offered her home
up for alacia's first six months
I think the most rewarding part is that
they feel safe here and it's nice the
challenge now nine months later and
without government support is to find
affordable housing close enough for
Alicia's two sons to stay at their
current schools well I can't put them
through the turmoil of
social housing which may not even be in
Worthing
so I'll offered another six months
but I think it has to be finite and for
their sake as well as mine they need to
make their own lives
for young artem that life includes art
now on display in a local gallery
what's this one
four
he's selling these cardboard sculptures
to raise money for Ukraine's Army
foreign
yes
guns this past year became a part of
many Ukrainian children's lives now
perhaps a key to a future return home
yes Villa Marx Al Jazeera Worthing
Southern England
and for the moment that's all from me in
cave back to you in Doha Turin
Adrian thank you all dozens of
independent journalists have escaped a
media Crackdown in Russia stepherson met
some of them in Amsterdam
they were in silence for very long TV
rain or dosht is again reaching out to
its Russian audience now from Amsterdam
the independent channel was banned in
Russia one week after the invasion of
Ukraine for its coverage of the war
like hundreds of other journalists
presenter Mikhail Fishman and Julia
taratuta fled Russia out of fear of
arrest
prominent voices
are silenced
either they are in jail or they are in
put in a position when they basically
can't open their mouth
since its Escape From Russia TV rains
audience has grown with nearly 4 million
subscribers and hundreds of thousands of
views each day this fight is is very
difficult for us and because you have to
understand that uh the annual budget of
Russian States me so propagandist it's
me more than one billion Euro and the
combined budget of 31 Russian media in
Exile is just 6.2 million euros we are
like David and Goliath well originally
an English language newspaper the Moscow
times has increased its readership by
also publishing in Russian Amsterdam has
become a new home for Russian media in
Exile the Moscow times was forced to
leave the country it was operating in
for nearly 30 years its sudden departure
shows how journalism and press Freedom
are among the victims of this war not
only in Russia but some say in Western
Europe as well this is RT International
when the European Union decided to ban
kremlin-backed media Russia Today and
Sputnik a few months into the war the
Dutch Federation for journalists
formally filed a complaint what we see
on RT or Sputnik we consider also as
propaganda and has not being independent
dualism
but at the same time we feel that it's
very worrisome
if a state if the political leadership
can decide on what people in also in in
European countries can see or not can
see
in Russia journalists risk 15 years in
prison just for using the word War it's
a military part has completely failed
but its inner propaganda part is
succeeding that we have to admit that uh
and well because this enemy is much
weaker
and easier to to crush
meanwhile TV rain fights hard to stay on
air offering a different narrative to
its Russian audience the channel was
recently banned in Latvia for comments
that were considered pro-russian the
channel is fighting that decision
stepfast al-jazeera Amsterdam
well let's now bring in a Katrina katri
katse she's the news director and anchor
at the independent Russian television
television channel TV rain that we just
saw on the report and she's joining us
from Georgia's capital to Belize thanks
for speaking to us so it's not really a
surprise that some governments will try
to secure the public narrative during
times of War One Year Ron do you think
the Kremlin is winning or is it losing
control of the narrative in Russia
it's hard to say because there is a
military censorship as my colleague has
just mentioned in Russian Federation you
don't know what the what the feelings of
the society are right now what we can
definitely know is that even State
Control polling stations are admitting
that the level of support of this war is
going down and down step by step because
this war is coming to the homes of you
know a lot of Russians of millions of
Russians because people are being
mobilized to go to the war so there are
people who were above the politics if
you can say so before that but right now
they are forced to understand what is
really going on in Ukraine and of course
as we just saw in the report your
Channel TV rain considered to be one of
the last independent TV stations in
Russia survived just one week after the
war started forcing you to relaunch from
Latvia and then more recently Latvia
canceled your license branding the
company threat to National Security I
mean how does all of this impact your
coverage of the war
it does not impact anyhow I mean the
fact that we were banned from Russia and
we will we were forced to flee the
country this is important unfortunately
I am in Felicia Georgia right now
reporting from here uh at this terrible
anniversary uh one year of War my
colleagues are in Riga some of them are
in in Amsterdam some of them are in
other parts of the world what we know is
that we need to keep on working we know
that we have millions of viewers we have
14 million unique viewers only on
YouTube monthly only from Russia what
I'm saying is that we can see that
people need us we know that there is a
terrible war crimes and crimes against
humanity being committed right now in
Ukraine we need to report about that and
we have a huge audience and it doesn't
matter what happened in Latvia we're
going to be fine we will remove we will
move to Amsterdam so it's it's not going
to be a problem for me okay we'll have
to leave it there thank you so much for
speaking to us from to belisi
so when the fog of War propaganda is
often used as a tool and during Russia's
war in Ukraine it's come in many forms
Laura Khan reports
propaganda often at the front and center
of Shoring up support for a nation at
War and Russia is no exception
these symbols of its war in Ukraine can
be found even outside of schools when a
war started propaganda increased
used only
hundred percent politically correct
words like ukrainians uh
uh chief
maximum they're calling uh give
government as a key regime
unless say Ukraine's strategy often
appeals on an emotional level and
Central to this is President Vladimir
zielinsky
often depicted as a figurehead of
bravery and resilience Ukraine cannot
engage and doesn't have enough resources
actually to engage in you know at the
same level of propaganda campaign as
Russia tokariac points out the many
campaigns are led by civil rights groups
some with humor but it's on social media
platforms that disinformation is
flourishing
last year this deep fake of zelenski
calling on soldiers to lay down weapons
was reportedly uploaded to a hacked
website
and game developer Bohemia interactive
released a statement after a video from
its game Armor 3 was falsely shared as a
war video
now journalists and experts are trained
in how to distinguish between real
combat videos and video games like armor
3. in a statement Bohemia interactive
set out how the public can spot a fake
and the red flags include a low screen
resolution
a darker screen to hide some of those
details
and strange particle effects as it's
very difficult to depict smoke fire and
dust in video games
online platforms have also been moving
to ban kremlin-backed State Media Tech
giants like YouTube and meta announced
they would ban Russia Today and Sputnik
which then shifted contents to alt Tech
platforms gab Rumble and odyssey they're
popular among the far right having been
established to evade big Tech censorship
and us-based intelligence firm nissos
Trace video being shared on Telegram and
Twitter from inauthentic accounts
linking many to Russian media Ministries
or officials
Russia's representative to the U.N
Vasily nabencia recently accused Western
countries of conducting an anti-russia
propaganda campaign
with so much disinformation and
conflicting narratives truth can be a
casualty when rallying support takes
precedence
Laura Khan Al jazeeran
well that's it from myself and the team
in Ukraine but we'll be back on Saturday
at these times looking at what's next
for Ukraine Russia NATO and The Wider
World thanks for watching and bye for
now